One of the most joyous moments in our relationship was when we heard that we won
the lawsuit and then you got down on one knee and proposed to me,
okay,
we have a very exciting relationship.
Our relationship is enduring and very,
very true love.
I would agree with that.
I like to say the first impression I had of Chrissy was that it was like,
it was like lust at first sight.
She was so beautiful and I was actually trying to introduce her to someone else.
Um,
but I just,
I got swept off of my feet by her beauty.
I mean,
she's just one of the most beautiful people I've ever seen and I can't believe I
married her.
She was everything that I had been dreaming of.
Literally that week I had been dreaming of going and meeting the woman of my
dreams.
I wanted to meet an artist.
I wanted her to have long,
brown hair.
I saw her and I was like,
oh my God,
she's,
she's right here.
She's in front of me.
I said,
it was lust at first sight.
And I said,
you were just like so beautiful.
And I can't believe I married you
when I first saw you.
It was literally like saying a dream come true.
I trimmed to view that week and even down to your hair.
And I walked out and there you were and you were like a vision and I was like,
oh my gosh,
there's the,
the rest of my life standing right in front of me.
That was so much more romantic than when I said you'll catch up.
Yeah.
Wow.
Huh.
Um,
oh,
our first real date was I picked her up and we went to a little restaurant and
she was like so skinny and like I had no idea like what,
how much this girl can eat.
And we went to a restaurant and she was like,
what are these like massive pile of fries and just like ate the whole thing
within like five minutes.
And then we went to go see a musical called spring awakening.
And I was crazy about her.
And at the end of the date I called my mom and was like,
I'm crazy about this girl.
She was like,
come on over.
I want to meet her.
Our first date was,
I believe it was October 3rd,
2011 she took me to see one of your all time favorite Broadway shows.
Spring awakening.
I already knew at that point that I was like,
I want to spend the rest of my life with this girl.
And I know I get carried away and like I fall so fast,
but I really did know.
And then he met her mom that night.
So I guess she knew to spring awakening.
What date?
The date?
Yeah,
in spring he took me for my
birthday.
Oh,
Tobar fifth it was October 3rd it's not your birthday.
So that's a trick question.
So did you say about the going to the restaurant first?
No,
I just said I already knew I wanted to spend my life with you and I didn't know
how you felt,
but then you took me to meet your mom.
So I guess you were thinking that too.
I said that they said they took you to meet.
My mom has tree left.
Hmm.
Having a relationship scrutinized by the hundreds of thousands of people is
really intense.
And I think that if we didn't really love each other,
we would have not made it through having a youtube channel ditch the truth.
We started daily vlogging and it nearly broke up our relationship because we
started realizing we weren't really interacting with each other,
but really interacting for a camera.
Most any couple who is a blogger who's been doing it for any substantial amount
of time would say that it's really damaging to their relationship.
You know,
Gosh,
I think having our channel in the limelight,
having a relationship in the limelight has affected us in a negative way.
I think that not having any,
any independence for a years,
you know,
our channel is Bria and Christie or email is Bria and Chrissy.
Um,
we kind of lost ourselves and just became one unit and I think that over the
last year we've been finally finding ourselves again.
I said that having the channel adds a significant amount of pressure.
That's all you said.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
It's like when we went on that tour boat,
no life jacket.
I said that having the channel adds an immense amount of pressure,
but also having the channel,
um,
allowed fans to remind us in those hardest times that they saw our true lab and
it was able to draw us back to like know what we have is really true love.
But I think that the channel and the blogging is incredibly destructive
and that's really the reason we were able to like sustain having a youtube
channel is because are we our relationships so genuine,
otherwise we would never,
never have made it.
And the positives was that we,
you know,
have all these wonderful memories that we get to look back on for the rest of
our lives.
I'm going to go along the lines of the Youtube,
the worst mistake that I ever made.
What's Chrissy did a bunch of pranks on me and it was like 10 and they were like
really annoying praying because like I can't have caffeine.
And she went to get my decaf coffee but it wasn't decaf and she gave it to me at
like seven.
Oh,
he's the worst night's sleep of my life.
Like she,
she just like pulled a bunch of really annoying pranks on me.
So I decided,
I was like,
oh,
I'll just get her back.
I'll just one upper,
oh God,
I should never have done this.
Hmm.
Okay.
So I broke up with her on camera.
I,
I don't know what the hell I was thinking anyways,
the worst,
worst,
worst idea to ever do something like that to someone you love.
And uh,
I was like,
oh my God,
I can't post this.
Because like she was crying and it was so sad.
She was like,
if I went through this,
you're going to post it on the Internet.
It's so easy.
You don't need to be smiling baby.
I would say that the,
the biggest mistakes that I've made in our relationship is
drinking.
I battled PTSD for nine years and during the case and the lawsuit and the
revenge porn,
like I just got into such a sad,
dark place in my mind and wanting to escape it.
There's two times that I drank and both times Bria thought that I was going to
die.
The doctor said,
I might die.
And um,
one was in 2013 and I was lucky to survive and I promised to never drink again.
and then the other was last Saturday when I relapsed and I drank again and I
almost died.
I put her through that twice and I hate,
I hate that.
And now I'm finally getting real true help for this disease.
But also I never,
I never want to die and I never want the person who loves me more than anyone
has ever loved me to have to go through that pain again.
I want to love myself,
which I clearly have struggled with.
I want to love myself in the same true way that Bree loves me.
I said the two worst mistakes that I made her,
my,
it's my drinking 2013 and then last Saturday,
what did he say?
I signed it.
Putting you,
putting you through twice now.
Um,
the fear of,
of death,
the fear of Homos,
Lucy may because of my torment and my mental anguish putting you through that
is,
is the two worst mistakes that I've made.
What did you say?
Um,
I said about the,
the youtube prank where I broke up with you.
Oh.
Oh,
all our shit's out there.
And
that's okay.
I don't mind being honest.
Yeah.
I told her
when she survived last week,
I told her that I made vows to her in sickness and in health and she's sick.
Yeah.
I've never been loved the way that Brianna loves me and I've never loved anyone
or anything in the way that I love Bria and I feel like that love can get us
through literally anything and it feels like we've been through everything.
Okay.
I would say one of the most incredible moments in our relationship was about a
year into our relationship.
We realized that we were going to have to enter a lawsuit and I'm Krissy became
the first ever person to pursue a lawsuit of this nature.
And four years,
four and a half years of fighting this lawsuit tie tirelessly.
Like,
Eh,
I mean it's just took up our lives.
Um,
we were in England and it got announced that we won the lawsuit.
And I'm getting to hear that moment and feel that moment with the person that
you love who had been fighting so hard for this accomplishment was just like
nothing I've ever experienced in my life.
And right after that moment she got down on one knee and proposed to me,
okay.
I would say a defining moment and our relationship was probably the like the day
that I found out I was a victim of revenge porn.
Um,
it was like our world came crashing down and we were crushed that whole week.
That defining,
defining moment was starting in case for me and I became like incapable of
functioning.
Like I was just so distraught.
My life had completely just shattered and Bria loved me so much.
She knew the terror that we were both feeling and she stayed strong,
stayed my rock and found us uninterrupted and like gave me the courage to pursue
this lawsuit.
Kept loving me through all the night terrors,
all of the pain,
all of the drinking,
all of the just anguish of PTSD and she stayed with me.
She gave me the strength to keep fighting when I didn't think that I could keep
fighting.
I didn't know if I could survive.
I think you knew that my answer would be like the moment that we found out about
the revenge porn.
Um,
that whole thing of you being there for me when I was completely crushed,
you know what my answer was?
Winning the lawsuit.
Uh,
that's so interesting because I think winning the was a defining moment for us,
but that was like the victorious part.
I think that the part of finding out and then you choosing to stay for five
years,
it's like that was the defining moment for me.
One of the most joyous moments in our relationship was when we hear that we won
the lawsuit and then you got down on one knee and proposed to me,
how could I not after you stuck by me for all those years.
That's like the only thing I could think of to celebrate.
So we did kind of say the same thing,
just different ends at the beginning and the end.
Yeah.
There's pretty much not a reason why I don't love her.
Our hearts just love each other
and I would do anything for you.
Yeah.
I just,
I,
I don't even know how to explain it.
I just can't help myself.
I can't help but love her.
It's like,
I don't know.
It's like our hearts were just destined to know each other.
It's like breathe.
It feels like home to me.
I can't help but love her.
Okay.
I said our hearts just
love each other
and,
um,
I would do anything for you.
I said,
I can't help but love you because it's like our hearts just know each other and,
um,
I just,
I can't help but love you.
Your heart feels like home to me.
You feel like home.
We want a good thumbnail.
I just want to kiss.
I know.
Gimme a kiss.
Don't do that.